Okay Michael, so
I think I have basically
one more thing that I want to say before
I start writing out little formulas and
trying to convince you that this
is something that we can do
with some of the framework and
infrastructure that we've built so far.
And I want to do it by diving in and
sort of doubling down on this idea
drama management,
this idea of going through a story.
So you're an AI person and you need to
kind of think about how you're going to
build a system where a player can
learn how to go through a story or
can go through a story and
have a good time.
So the first question I'm going to claim
you're going to have to ask yourself
is well, what's a story?
What's a story really?
And for the purposes of this discussion,
I'm going to just assert something and
you can tell me if it
makes sense to you.
And that is that a story,
it turns out, is just a trajectory.
It's just one of any possible many
number of possible trajectories
through a space that is
made up of plot points.
So, does that make any sense to you?
Do you know what I mean by that?
>> So you're being abstract
about what stories are.
Yes I'm being very abstract.
That abstraction is important
because we're computationalists.
>> And plot points, I guess plot points
makes me picture a graph where there's
points and there's edges or
there's vertices and there's edges.
So plot point is like a vertex?.
>> Yes, right.
So a plot point is like a little circle,
and that plot point might represent
something like, I don't know,
what's your favorite kind of story?
>> Mystery.
>> You like mysteries.
Okay cool.
So I have a plot point, that's something
that has to do with the mystery.
So what happens in a mystery?
So there's a murder.
What?
Yes that's a plot point.
There's another plot point maybe and
that plot point is
there's an accusation.
There's another plot point
which is a weapon is found.
And there's a whole bunch of these and
if they're set up right and
they're sequenced just right if of all
the possible paths of all the possible
plot points were set up just right.
So you see the murder, you see the
accusation, a weapon is found and so on.
Then you have something that
looks like a murder mystery.
Now I want to point out that it's
possible to have good murder mysteries
and bad murder mysteries.
So if you think about the way
a murder mystery works right,
it's got this really neat structure.
There's a murder.
Nobody knows who did it,
that's what makes it a mystery.
And then eventually you discover that,
every
single person in the house had a reason
to kill the person who was killed.
And you find a weapon that
points to a particular person.
>> It's, Michael.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Everyone know it's that person and
then that person gets killed.
>> That's Michael again
>> No!
>> And then you know
therefore it wasn't Michael.
>> Or Curley.
>> And so, then you keep going And
you discover it was in fact not Curly.
And then you find out who
the real murderer is and
there's a whole bunch of things
that happen very quickly.
And it turns out it was
the butler all along.
>> That would've been my guess.
>> And
that makes it a good murder mystery.
Now here's a bad murder mystery.
There's a murder and you happen to see
it and so you know who the murderer is.
>> [LAUGH].
>> So then a murderer has to go off and
start killing you and
everyone else they can.
You run away and
you know what you've got instead?
>> A chasing movie.
>> You've got a horror movie.
So the difference between a murder
mystery and a horror movie, and
not that much difference,
it's really about whether you know
who's doing the killing or not.
So if I have all these elements lined
up in some kind of virtual game.
Depending upon what the player of the
game is doing I may have to interfere,
interact with what's actually going
on underneath so that the player
experiences a murder mystery as opposed
to experiencing a horror flick.
>> And when you say you might have that,
you mean the drama manager.
>> Right, because the agent can describe
what it means to be a murder mystery.
And as a player,
the author can't control the players.
The player's going through.
The system may have to interact
with that in order to make
certain that you still get a good murder
mystery as opposed to something else.
And I'm going to claim that if we
think of these points as being key
things that happen in the story and
some sequences are better than others
then what we end up with
is a story is a trajectory.
It's a trajectory through
these plot points.
And that a good story is
a particular kind of trajectory.
And there are bad stories which
are other kinds of trajectories.
And we need to figure out
how to influence the player
in such a way that we go
down the good trajectories.
Instead of the bad trajectories.
>> And can you say a word about
what the player's doing here?
>> Well so
it would depend upon the situation.
But imagine that.
I mean you play games like Zork.
>> [LAUGH] Sure.
>> And various other things.
Right?
Sure you have vague memories of
Hitchhiker's Guide To The Galaxy.
And those like text adventure games.
You're interacting with the system
somehow and you decide to go north or
you decide to open the door,
you decide to talk to somebody.
It's just like you choose
your own adventure story,
that's the kind of idea that
I'm trying to evoke here.
>> Interesting.
Okay, and so
you're saying that we could think
of this as a kind of MDP and
then do reinforcement learning in it?
>> Yes,
that's what I'm going to talk about.
I want to convince you, if you buy this
idea of story, as trajectory with plot
points and it's actually pretty
easy to turn it into an MVP.
>> Okay,
I would like to hear about that.
>> Okay, let's do that.